[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Jamie is
with us in Alberta hi Jamie welcome
Alberta Canada welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi thanks J for taking my call sure
what's
up um I just wanted to say uh my husband
and I started your baby step last
September so about a year now and uh we
did the whole beans and rice I sold
everything we had and and I went back to
work we got completely debt free paid
off 40,000 in debt fully funded
emergency fund and are now and we've
already been putting um our 15% away
into retirement so now we're kind of on
step I guess five and six um but we've
kind of come to a bit of a I don't know
feels like stagnant spot now in this
plan because my husband's lost
motivation because you know we
accomplished so much and he's not really
Keen to pay down the mortgage
um he thinks wait a minute a Canadian
that doesn't want to pay down their
mortgage do you know how weird that
is well I I guess yeah I I mean he wants
to but not at the expense of us not
having any fun for the
next years of our life well there is
some something to be said about that
because you're used to the intensity of
baby step one two and three right it's
you're just going hard in the paint
every dollar is going to that but it
doesn't have to be like that for baby
step
six I know but I get out of that he does
and I want to stay in this mentality
because those baby that oh teaches you
how you're just kind of gluttonous and
you want things you don't need and no
he's not glut he just would like to eat
occasionally yeah he you've not been
feeding the boy he wants a new pair of
jeans
okay well it's not so much that it's
bigger stuff like he wants because right
now if he works on overtime shifts he
brings in about an extra $600 just for
one shift so he works a couple of those
a month he wants all that extra money to
go towards a camper or like a piece of
land for our us and our kids to enjoy
which I'm like I want to do that but not
until we have like do you have the money
to save up for that piece of land and
like aside from the $600 that he's
getting for this overtime do you have
other money to put towards the mortgage
oh yeah we probably have every month we
probably have an extra $2,000 that just
kind of
isn't doing much you got to let him have
the
600 no no no no no no no not the 600 it
may be a, it may be 400 it's not his
overtime is not relevant he's not it's
the here's what we're going to do okay
we're going to move after baby step
three from intense scorched Earth beans
and rice rice and beans ramen noodles
we're going to move away from that in
baby steps four five and six from
intense to intentional intentional means
these are the stages at which you pay
cash and upgrade your car these are the
stages you save up and buy an
inexpensive paid for used camper not a
$300,000 camper oh no okay this is the
stage at which we go on vacation this is
the stage at which we can put going out
to eat back in the budget this is the
stage if we need to replace the
20-year-old mattress we pay cash for it
and replace the mattress this is
intentional not intense and some of
those things are going to slow down if
you had what you could to put towards
the house but you're going to do some of
those things because it's a longer slog
to pay off the house you know you're
you're moving from sprinting to
marathoning yeah Jamie let me ask you a
question and my knowledge on this is
somewhat slim but I do know in Canada
your interest rate changes every several
years right like every five years every
10 years is that right is it is that
what you're trying to avoid is there any
part of that that um kind of yeah so
we've just resigned for five years
mortgage right before rates went up so
we're only paying 2.2% which is awesome
no you just got your you just got the
pedal to the metal and you don't want to
let up she doesn't exactly you are still
going to pay off your you're still going
to pay off your mortgage so fast you
will how much is a balance on how much
is a balance on your
mortgage uh about 400,000 what's your
household
income um depend like is that including
the overtime generally it's about
200,000 combined okay so when do you
think you're going to pay off the house
like five
years well if it's my husband's way it
won't be for 15 no your husband's not
really saying 15 you're
whining it's not all or nothing well
honestly it's okay originally when we
started your baby steps we wanted 10
years you could do it if with intensity
you could do it in three and a half to
four years course I agree I want no no
no no no no no no but I am not going to
recommend that okay I'm not going to
recommend three and have to four I'm
going to recommend five or six and buy
an inexpensive camper I would not buy
the land I'd buy a nice camper I'd buy
some things around the house loosen up
and enjoy your life a little so it
sounds like if if you are really telling
the truth about him I think you're
exaggerating his position but if you're
really telling the truth about him what
we're telling you to do is between you
two but I'm thinking he's probably
closer to where we are and you're just
all riled up she's a All or Nothing
personality it's like I love it that's
what got you of course that's wonderful
but it's not sustainable over 4 years 5
years it's very difficult to do that you
all did it over a long period of time
but you in baby step 2 the whole time
yes and you didn't have a choice look
Sam and I have had that conversation and
I am the one that's like put all the
money on the house and he's like calm
down we're not doing
that yeah